wann opferte union arme und ein zweites
thema die union wird armin laschet es
dann opfern wenn wirklich die jamaika
option zumindest jetzt im ersten schritt
dahin ist also wenn fdp und grüne klar
sagen wir machen jetzt sondierung wir
machen koalitionsverhandlungen mit der
spd dann bedeutet das für armin laschet
aus meiner sicht das ganz sichere ende
warum weil dann die mögliche
machtoptionen am tisch zu sitzen das was
einige noch zurückhält obwohl man sagen
muss wenn man sich die spitze dort
anschaut und wie sie miteinander reden
und was übereinander sagen dann ist das
ja schon so böse das man weiß dass am
ende amila steht sowieso nicht überleben
könnte aber bislang hält ihn so ein
bisschen diese ganz ganz kleine
machtoptionen was jamaican gilt ich
denke dass wenn das scheitern sollte das
kann diese woche passieren ist dann ganz
schnell gehen könnte in der union dass
es dann ganz schnell jemanden geben
könnte der versucht zumindest
kommissarisch oder sich dann auf den
parteivorsitz zu bewerben und dann ist
die hoffnung in der union was ist denn
wenn die ampel doch noch scheitern
sollte also wenn man sich dann in ein
zwei monaten zwischen spd und fdp bei
steuerfragen über wird dann könnte ein
neuer starker mann aus der union
möglicherweise übernehmen und da doch
noch hoffnungen auf das kanzleramt habe
vielen dank paul wir wollen mal ganz
schnell noch auf die person armin
laschet schauen und wer dachte dass er
jetzt wenigstens gut gelaunt in die
erste sondierungsrunde mit den grünen
heute um 11 uhr starten kann er hat sich
getäuscht denn bei diesen zahlen werden
wohl ein paar weitere falten bei armin
laschet dazu kommt thomas minder
meinungs- trend verlieren cdu csu nach
der bundestagswahl noch einmal 3,1
prozentpunkte und kommen nur noch auf 21
prozent währenddessen steigt die spd um
2,3 prozentpunkte auf 28 prozent aber
nicht nur diese zahlen haben ihnen so
rapide altern lassen wir schauen uns
noch mal an was inhaltlich so auf armin
laschet zugekommen ist in den zeiten
seit der bundestagswahl und was ihn so
hat altern lassen wir schauen mal auf
die augen und dann erinnern wir uns an
die abgabe des stimmzettels die falscher
abgabe er hat ihn falsch gefaltet und
jeder konnte sehen was er gewählt hat
zwei kreuzchen bei der cdu damit klar
gegen das wahlgeheimnis verstoßen die
haare sind grauer geworden auch als dann
das ergebnis bekannt gegeben worden ist
armin laschet hat der cdu/csu in ein
historisches tief geführt das war am
wahlsonntag und natürlich sind die
falten am und größer geworden als dann
kurz danach markus söder sofort
gestichelt hat er hat anders als armin
laschet olaf scholz zum wahlsieg
gratuliert und gesagt die spd ist ganz
klar der wahlsieger das hat armin
laschet lange nicht über die lippen
gebracht dafür hat sich dann friedrich
merz zu wort gemeldet hat gesagt beim
nächsten mal müsse es auf jeden fall
einen mitgliederentscheid geben also
alle cdu mitglieder sollen befragt
werden nicht so wie jetzt als armin
laschet
parteivorsitzender wurde und dann zum
kanzlerkandidaten aufgerufen wurde heißt
also im umkehrschluss hätten wir damals
schon die mitglieder gefragt wäre ich
friedrich merz wahrscheinlich gewählt
worden und das ist auch ein neuer plan
und dann natürlich die sorgenfalten auf
der stirn als jens spahn noch mal gesagt
hat armin laschet war sicherlich ein
kandidat der nicht gezogen hat
dann war ja
und wer dachte dass armin laschet jetzt
wenigstens das haben schon die garage
ist jetzt dran unsere koalitions
reporterin die ami lasche zeit wochen
begleitet und natürlich an dich die
frage annika ja wie hast du ihn denn
jetzt erlebte vom frischen gut gelaunten
gebräunten armin laschet zum grauen
trostlosen armin laschet kann man es so
sagen
man kann auf jeden fall sagen dass ihm
die letzten zwei wochen viel mehr
zugesetzt haben als sie sechs wochen
wahlkampf und die arminia sechs wochen
lang begleitet und wir wissen wie
anstrengend die sechs wochen waren und
wie man von termin zu termin gerast aber
ich kann jetzt sagen als eine die ihn
wirklich sechs wochen lang begleitet hat
das der moment der wahl wirklich alles
verändert hat weil wir haben dann am
nächsten morgen gesehen an dem montag
morgen nach der wahl und da kann man aus
der landesvertretung in berlin
morgens raus und ist zum konrad adenauer
haus gefahren wir uns das erste mal
angeschaut haben gesagt mensch man sieht
ihm jetzt wirklich diese strapazen an
das war das erste mal dass wir wirklich
gedacht haben dass er wirklich schwere
zeiten durchgemacht hat weil er am
anfang wirklich egal was passiert ist
egal welche panne dazwischen gekommen
ist oder in die er sich sozusagen selbst
bisschen gestürzt hat man hat ihm das
nie wirklich angesehen und ich glaube es
war so der moment als das schwarz auf
weiß die zahlen gesehen hat und gesehen
hat er hat diese wahl verloren das
sicher auch wirklich was getan hat armin
laschet selbst spricht aber immer noch
davon bis heute davon dass alle dass er
noch immer noch alle chancen hat
viele schmundt sind darüber ist entfernt
sich auch immer mehr mitstreiter das
heißt die zeit wird für ihn immer immer
schwerer aber ich glaube das was armin
laschet ausmacht ist dass er wahnsinnig
kämpferisch ist und das muss man ihm
wirklich lassen er ist wahnsinnig
kämpferisch bis heute was viele für
ignorant halten mögen vielleicht auch
berechtigt aber er ist kämpferisch und
er sieht bis heute nicht ein dass er den
zweiten platz belegt aber man sieht es
ihnen auf jeden fall an dass die letzten
wochen nicht gerade einfach waren annika
wie gesagt um 11 uhr treffen sich union
und grüne zum ersten mal zu
sondierungsgesprächen was erwartest du
da
das wird auf jeden fall nicht einfach
wir haben ja auch gestern dann die den
das fdp zitat gehört also dass werden
schwere stunden für armin laschet wenn
nicht sogar seine letzten in der in der
jetzigen rolle sozusagen
[Musik]